welcome to making Bank I am Josh Felber
and again we are here with Gary
Vaynerchuk welcome nicking Bank may be
back I like the back oh man well welcome
back buddy thank you brother
after a 48 hour travel truth its 11
hours in Australia you're in clear is it
normal to go Sydney to Cleveland is that
the north yes everybody's doing that
right you skip everything else comes
through here I wish there was a director
the Honolulu and Chicago lay overs were
pretty interesting so all right let's do
it
cool ma'am welcome back to the show deaf
last time we were kind of chatting a
little bit about your book yes and I
can't want to dive in a little bit more
it's nice I've got exposure now things
are happening I mean give us a little
you know is the book doing what you want
it to do yeah the books actually doing
better than I thought it was going to do
to be really frank with you I think in
hindsight I should have realized that
the show the Q&A show is me at my best
for me which is I get to talk
philosophically and in detail okay and
so unlike my other three books which
they either took one or the other tactic
this one's a little more 360 and so
we're one weekend and my best buds who
know all my [ __ ] liked it quite a bit
and people that actually think I'm a
little too much there a little too much
bravado or caught me in the wrong light
have been emailing me and say they like
it and so this definitely the best
feedback I've ever gotten on a book
awesome and I've seen some of those
testimonials popping up people like oh
man I didn't really connect with Gary
and yeah listen to the audiobook yep
which is toy giver than the book almost
yeah I decided to do something
interesting I'm not a very I'm actually
a terrible reader and so which is you
know a lot of times I make the joke that
I've almost written as many books as I
read and I think it's because I'm not a
good reader I mean I just a waste of
time I can't retain what information
very well that way so I'm doing the
audiobook and I'm reading and I'm like
this is gonna take forever because the
book is big yeah and I was like okay
I've got an idea
let's not do that so instead I had a
bunch of my buddies read questions for
the book and so I just sat in a booth
and answer to them as if it was the
first time we're hearing it luckily
they're pretty consistent with what I
wrote but some of it adjusted a little
bit yeah we were talking about you
I that's really cool that you shot
because that I did that with the
audiobook it's the first time I've heard
of people reading and listening to the
audiobook you said you did that but this
has been a challenge because they're
different different yeah yeah you start
going off and yeah adding all this cool
extra content and it's like oh man okay
cool I usually take notes following
right along but it's been a having to
you know just stop one and just clearly
absorb audiobook and then go back and
pick up the bridge thank you Dan so so I
guess what was the whole I guess purpose
and drive behind this specific book it
was very selfish and I want to be very
frank about this I'm obsessed with Q a
sure I want to do Q a and I decided 18
months ago to make myself a little bit
more known for Q a that's why I started
the show with the book and now I can go
to conferences and just be Q aid or just
do Q&A you know I'm not big enough yet
where I can go into any venue and go
okay everybody you know my spiel let's
do Q&A so I still probably but if I can
get to a place where I go 15 minutes
spiel 45 QA versus 45 and 15 that would
be really great I love the stage I love
QA I think I get to show my best version
of myself in QA cuz I get to show that I
actually know what the hell I'm talking
about the problems and just like even
details right like I'm a practitioner in
snapchat and Facebook live and in
Twitter and and I think that um there's
a lot of people headline reading or
watching other people and just grabbing
onto quotes that I mean I've literally
sit in presentations where people talk
about product and incorrect way sure
like just say do this and the product
doesn't do that so I take a lot of pride
in my actual knowledge and usage of
these things or theories or philosophies
and so yeah awesome well so one of the
things you talked a little bit about it
in the book as well as on some of your
shows everything there's a whole family
and kitch I mean I have three kids
myself and a wife and I mean I you said
before I met you and really dove into
who you were I mean I thought I was the
badass house giving you you know a lot
of people reducing need to get air cover
with their husband or wife about how
much they weren't they're like well Gary
look
that is exactly so you know how do I
deal with this yeah because people talk
about balance I think that's you know
well balance is first generation I think
it is you know an integration is look
here's the real answer I have no
interest in telling people how to parent
their children and I have no interest in
telling people how to manage their
work-life balance with their spouse or
their partner right like you know every
relationship is different like you just
everybody's got their own stuff and so
my key is to over communicate with
Lizzie like that's what I have to do
what I have to do for a living is it for
the most important thing is to over
communicate with my partner and now as
my children or six and three and I can
see it already she's almost of seven now
you know now misha's got her opinions on
and I have to factor those in and so
it's constant adjustment I'm working
harder today than I did more hours today
than I did thirty six months ago but I
may decline over the next seven to ten
years because those might be formative
years for the kids or who knows or been
the truth is or I may work more like or
we you know we may find the balance of
you know let's be insane about weekends
and vacations and you know my kids my
intuition is my kids are gonna be very
over programmed and they're gonna be on
nine to five and and really not because
we live in Manhattan but because there's
so much they want to do and there's so
much you can do and and by the way if
they don't want to that's fine too but I
think what my point with that little
story is is it's a it's communicating
and adjusting daily sure and that's how
we deal with it I think that makes sense
I mean because you can't really always
know where it's gonna be two weeks from
now if my dad gets sick tomorrow I'm not
gonna work at all
yeah like like I don't understand why
people think like this is a thesis that
can be your thesis like like like I
don't know I'm working more now that I
did in my 20s when I should have worked
the most but I thought I worked a lot
then I was working 12 hours a day now
working more that blows my mind that was
not something I could have ever foreseen
are you gonna work more as a 40 year old
man with two kids then as a 24 year old
that wants to rule the world no way I
would have won that bet yeah
I'm the same way and one of the things -
I know you said you do is you take it
you you integrate seven weeks of
vacation yes as well to really just
totally shut down spend time with the
family as things increased on 15-hour
days that I could I really added to
travel I was like okay two weeks
vacation is just not enough just net net
time I think what I've done in these
last three years as it's gotten crazy is
been completely shut down on weekends
you know even there right now is I'm
addicted to snapchat just talking my
friends here sorry you could see on the
weekends like I'll sneak one in when I
have to take Xander to the store just
because I feel I want to get something
out there but I'm really off I'm really
with the fam I'm really focused and then
and then on vacation
I've gotten really great I've really
started shutting down and really all in
and look it might be not enough for some
people might be enough for other people
I don't know I mean when I think about
52 weeks and I can get you know 12% mean
it's a there's like a lot of time feels
like a lot of time and so we just bought
a summer home so I'm gonna try to work
from home on Fridays now and do calls
and interviews not Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday trying to stack them
in on Friday so by 5:00 o'clock maybe I
could that's another six hours that I'm
buying back to family that I never did
before because of that new variable so
it's just adjusting and the key is you
know is being present and you know when
you're totally shutting down the key the
key is to be happy with yourself right
like I have no interest in making you
happy about my work-life balance
you worry about your work-life balance
like my key is first me and this is in
order then my kids and my wife because
if I'm happy then I can do anything for
them and that's it right and that's what
I that's what matters and and if this
feels good for now then great and that's
it and the only thing that can waver
from what I want to do is a real belief
that I'm doing the wrong thing by my
family because either my daughter might
my son or my wife tell me they're very
unhappy with the allocation that I'm
getting right now but like my wife ended
up being way more independent than I
thought yeah like I never saw that
coming I didn't see my wife being like I
could secretly think my wife has
husband's somewhere she's just so not
into me Lizzie come on like she's so
independent she's on her stuff and like
that pup clearly makes it work to
definites the same way my wife is I
think I just who I attracted
yeah that's why I was so and that you
know I can't believe leads me you know I
know that you're talking like don't be
me
bú shì dive in a little bit more I mean
like yeah I mean you know Esalen hard
I'm super I'm super pumped what's like
the attention and admiration that I'm
getting but it scares me because I don't
want people to do what I'm doing because
I know that I'm very first of all I feel
like I'm an extremely unique dude I've
always been unique my whole life I've
always done stuff so differently so it
doesn't feel like I'm a good blueprint
for a lot of people like it doesn't feel
practical doesn't feel practical that
you can work 18 hours a day without
eating or drinking you know this is why
I've been throwing around the robot
emoji on my social lately because my
brother coined this a long time ago
inside the family and now I'm because of
dailyvee my daily vlog where people
really see it's true yeah I mean like I
don't think I'm a good cop
sure and so I think you have but I'm
happy for me and I want people to be
happy for them and and if that means
nine to five and if that means
forty-nine thousand a year in income and
you're happy as hell well then you've
won because I've got miserable friends
making ten million dollars a year oh
yeah definitely
I'm just diving a little bit of
marketing real yeah see I you
I like marketing snapchat you're all
you're on the snapchat hype you're you
know yeah I got oh man Sean now down
look are you Donna Stevenson's in
snapchat
yes get in there brother uh I follow
attention right you know lately somebody
I know you know some of you it sounds
like you know I'm kind of saying now I
day trade attention that's what I do for
a living I look at attention and that's
been my career as a 40 now I know what I
am I'm a person that day trades
attention that's why I like T comm and
email marketing and Google Adwords and
Facebook and Twitter and YouTube and now
snapchat in 24 months the far majority
of Americans under the age of 45 will be
spending a lot of time on snapchat
that's important the end whether you
want to raise money for your NGO or get
your you know soap
business off the ground or if you want
to get elected for mayor attention is
what you need before you tell people
what you've got and you've got to go
where it's going and I like going where
it's under priced like TVs got attention
but it would take up all my time and I
don't have a good business deal by being
in the star of a TV show and so where is
it under priced snapchat is conducive to
very quick thoughts and ideas no you can
have your date my my name just your name
and so you know we'll work on that that
I'll help you uh and so take something
temporary it's gonna be there and so I
think that people that are watching
right now that are selling real estate
to 38 to 52 year old couples they don't
think snapchats important because 14
year old girls are on it my point is if
you're gonna run a marathon you have to
start doing a 5k or get on the treadmill
so the quicker you start understanding
how to sell real estate on snapchat it's
gonna take you a year to really get a
cadence down and by the time you do if
the markets there and you're the only
one doing it there well then you become
the biggest broker in in you know Malibu
yeah and that's you know the interesting
thing is that you have those stories
popping out daily on snapchat you know
just kind of what is happening in your
life for a lot of you that don't know
stories is the main product of snapchat
where you get to put out content bits
and pieces and it sits there for 24
hours and every piece of content expires
at 24 hours so it's this rolling story
it's a very unique different social
network it's a little bit YouTube it's a
little bit Twitter it's a little bit
Instagram it's very very different but
it's very powerful and you should go to
YouTube and and literally type in how do
you snapchat there's thousands of videos
if you allocate three hours of your time
into it you really understand what to do
after watching a bunch of them and it
will it will be a game-changer I think
it will be a game-changer for a lot of
you so we're eating the whole social
media marketing segments heading I know
you got snapchat you know what do we see
in 2017 2008 I don't like predicting as
you know I like reacting but I think
Facebook has an absolute stranglehold on
the American attention between Facebook
and Instagram for the next three years I
feel very comfortable saying that I
think Twitter's got evolve or it will
fundamentally go the way of tumblr and
MySpace and Google Plus which is a
second
very third-tier platform I think
snapchat will be a monster and I think
inevitably something will pop up that we
don't even know right now that will be
very important in 24 months and you know
we've talked a little brief Lee you know
musically yeah yeah musically anchored
peach
you know after school these are things
I'm watching but they're all like you
know they're all penny stocks that I'm
kind of watching still early early cool
hey you know how do you continue to
operate such a high level of performance
I mean grata travel and for gratitude
gratitude gratitude I'm just so grateful
and it just drives the crap out of me
like I don't know like I got to be a
person like I really do I know you guys
some of you have heard that like the
math around becoming a human being is so
insane yeah and then so wait a minute
you're telling me that I got to be a
human and I got to be a white man in
America I believe that every white man
that lives in America should be put in
jail if they complain that is my new
belief that is a law that I would like
to pass if you were a white man in
America you've literally won the
universe you've won it sure you've won
the Universe lottery shut the [ __ ] up
like like like everybody else should
complain more than you yeah no I what
I'm right all right like like like
Newton figure I don't want to hear it
from you you need you need figure out to
be born in America like you just were
born and you were white and you're in
America you won so I'm hungry and driven
and excited and happy because I know the
alt I can feel it my soul the
alternative which is almost everything
else almost every other human being
almost every other animal like I don't
want to be a giraffe yeah like that's
not the best like every human won that
game if you were the most poor human
minority in in a very small village in
the middle of nowhere you beat the
giraffe right yeah you gotta run fast or
a flower that just gets picked and dies
like I don't know like I don't know I'm
very very grateful and then on top of
all that I think I was gifted with some
talents that are interesting you could
have been an athlete
and that's cool but you're done at 30 or
35 and I get to do my businessman thing
forever so I'm just grateful that's what
drives me that's awesome and you get
everybody over there working on snapchat
good good man
makes me happy man like like when I look
back when I get emails right now of the
people that I the last time I was
probably this emphatic was probably
Twitter you know Facebook ads and that's
worked for people but I was already like
a different kind of thing it wasn't the
platform itself it was a tactic within a
big platform and like I get emails every
day like you made me go on Twitter my
this happened because of like and I mean
like I got married because of it I
started a business because of it I
helped my friend find his lost dog
because of it like the whole gamut and I
feel like I'm gonna get those emails in
40 years about this - awesome
we got a few minutes left guys so why
don't dive in you know really what is a
what is your life's purpose I think it's
equally massively selfish and extremely
noble which is I want to build an empire
on the back of good I want to build an
enormous Liebig business because I love
capitalism I love business it's Who I am
I want to build a billion I want to buy
the New York Jets I want to document the
entire process for probably from the
time I was 32 time I'm 70 or 65 when I
do it I want to create 35 years of
content of me chasing something doing it
the best and most right way that I know
how which i think is very good and very
nice and the right way behind the scenes
and in public and then I want to achieve
it and then I want to be the blueprint
for everybody of ok I can achieve
anything at the highest of levels and be
a good person along the way that would
be an incredible way to go into the
ground
definitely anyway that's what a lot of
people really kind of struggle with the
whole thing is you know what is my
purpose I think I know my I really do I
think I'm meant to pull off a very big
thing in public and become a blueprint
for I've always been able to motivate
people I never knew that I would do it
in public there was kids in my class I
was like my dodgeball
it was it was my siblings it was my
neighbor I was always that guy the fact
that now it's not a bigger plane and it
will continue to grow and and I think
it's pretty cool I don't I don't think
we've ever in the world had the hard
core documentation of somebody setting
out a ridiculously big goal and drawing
it out for a very long period of time
like I'm really excited to like I really
really really am excited to go to the
premiere of the movie made of my life of
pulling it off like I really think
that's gonna happen like I truly believe
that I'm gonna be a fairly good-looking
old dude going to the premiere of my
movie and being super pumped some
hot-looking of the moment Hollywood dude
is playing me and like I truly believe
that's gonna happen I truly believe that
I'm gonna create a public narrative that
everybody's gonna know about where I
took 40 years to accomplish something I
wanted in the best way possible and it
becomes a modern-day blueprint in the
way that the Steve Jobs thing bothered
me in the other direction which was when
he passed on when his narrative was
starting to be formed it was that he was
a tough bad guy and it got the best out
of people and I want to I want to
inspire people with honey not with
vinegar awesome and that and that's what
you do by creating the value I mean
you're all about creating value and I
mean I think the landscape is you know
really shifted over the last several
years is you know especially with online
internet marketing and everything else
it was like hey you know opt in and I'll
give you something and you're you yeah I
think to give you you know look now it's
more like hey I need you've to you I
think I've even been unfair to the
people running masterminds and
conferences and ebooks because I'm being
so aggressive and I'm lumping everybody
into it and it's a good opportunity to
say look there's different versions of
everything but yeah you're right
I I'm looking to really give away the
best I mean I watch it every day I watch
people repackage my free information for
my show into sellable assets online and
I watch people and I'm fascinated by it
but it you know
yeah I've chosen my path I want to I
want to put out the best content in the
world that I can and then every three
years I want to sell something for 18
bucks and that's my that's my cadence
cool man and last thing
we do a book giveaway sure awesome so we
got some extra books I figure so we'll
have you come opt-in grab Gary B's book
and you know what all the contest
information will be right you know on
our link next to the video here awesome
man and we'll ship some people some cool
free hope you guys enjoy it when they
get a to your home
well I really appreciate you back on
Mickey Bank and so to be able to connect
it with you again I am Josh Bell Bert
and you were watching making Bank get
out and be extraordinary
you